hello everyone I'm Dana Perino this is a
Fox News Alert a terrifying ordeal in
the skies at 30,000 feet a Southwest
Airlines jet blew an engine today midair
while on its way to New York City
leaving an opening in the plane that
nearly sucked somebody out one passenger
is dead
Julie Ben Darras joins us from our
newsroom with the full story Julie yeah
that's right one person dead several
others injured on board this Southwest
Airlines jet the engine actually
exploded in midair 30,000 feet in the
sky the flight from New York to Dallas
made an emergency landing in
Philadelphia this morning and in the
thick of it all a harrowing rescue in
midair there are multiple reports
witnesses saw a piece of shrapnel from
the engine blow out a window and a
female passenger was then partially
sucked out of that window hole before
her fellow fliers scrambled to her
rescue she unfortunately later died
still unknown what her injuries were
that caused her death sadly but listen
to one passenger describe his horror
story
my wife is their third trimester to
articulate unbelievable the FAA says the
emergency landing on flight 1380
happened at 11:20 this morning after the
crew reported damage to one of the
aircraft's engines the fuselage and a
window passengers are seen exiting the
plane using those air stairs some of the
passengers have been sharing their
harrowing stories on social media such
as Marty Martinez he briefly in fact
went live even on Facebook and there you
see him wearing an oxygen mask and in
his post he wrote this engine exploded
in the air and blew open window three
seats away from me imagine that being
one of his friends on Facebook reading
that he says the explosion injured a
female sitting in the seat next to the
window the plane departed from New
York's LaGuardia Airport tracking data
from flight where dot-com shows the
flight was heading west over New York's
southern tier before abruptly turning
toward Philadelphia but Dana when you
look back at these pictures you have to
wonder how incredible and how many
heroes were on board that plane not just
the pilots to land that thing with one
engine but the crew members and the
passengers on board that tried to save
this woman sadly she later died at the
airport at the hospital Julie is that
confirmed it was the same woman we do
believe that that is the same woman but
we don't know exactly what the cause of
her death was but we do know that she
was hit in the head by shrapnel so we
don't know if she was conscious or not
when she was actually sucked through the
whole of the window it's a very
horrifying story thanks Julie appreciate
your reporting so Kimberly the NTSB is
on the ground it is the first passenger
fatality on a u.s. airline since 2009
can you imagine a track record pretty
good track record very sad you know
obviously our thoughts and prayers go
out to the family of the woman who is
deceased with that into the reporting
Vetta
Julie just did but you know obviously
the airplane is there safe I mean people
say generally flying is safer even than
driving but sometimes these type of
catastrophes unforeseen
can happen but what you see here again
is the human spirit people jumping in
trying to help one another and then
thoughts and reflections about you know
your life we get up in the morning and
we expect that we're gonna go to bed
that night just gives you a bit of pause
to say sometimes it was totally random
things can happen out of the blue and in
the blue like this particular situation
but they're good they'll do a full and
thorough investigation get all the
forensics find out what happened and
then there'll be issues as to whether or
not there's any culpability liability on
the part of Southwest was there any in
terms of the engine logs or the records
maintenance logs for the airplane to
determine if there was any kind of
forewarning that something might have
been wrong before this happened so you
know Dana when you said nothing beef
nothing since 2009 you're exactly right
but you know for me as a frequent flyer
gambler I always think if I get on a big
plane I'm not gonna have a problem the
small planes would go back to o9 there
was a small plane I think that had an
de-icing problem in Buffalo and before
that you go back to like 2006 and it was
a small plane coming out of Kentucky and
it had a short runway didn't quite get
up and then crash and then you lose I
think in both cases you lost 45 50
people in this case you're on a big
plane a Boeing 737 they never have
problems that I think I don't know when
the last time an engine exploded but you
never hear this this is really an
extraordinary event for people who fly
airplanes because we all think American
aviation is so safe and the big planes
never have a problem people worry about
props little planes but this is a big
one and so I only fly private the only
way to go that's good to know every man
of all he's a man of the people but
landing back in maybe New York on the
way to Dallas then that's inventive
Philly that was a probably a long 20
minutes yeah I mean I've had this
happened to me once it wasn't obviously
this severe but I remember texting my
mother saying I love you and thinking I
was gonna go down I guess the less what
did you call me and I you know I guess
maybe one of the lessons is when they're
doing
safety demonstration to pay attention as
if you're in the exit row and you don't
know what you're doing or you don't know
how to operate your air mask that's very
important it looks like there were a lot
of heroes out there you take safety for
granted when you fly in this country
this never happens in America and it
shouldn't happen in America we're to
advanced and to well-regulated and
obviously this was a freak accident and
the investigations gonna show what
happened but you hear about this in
other countries a lot in Africa and
Egypt and Malaysia or Ukraine and it
just speaks to how you know kind of
advanced and proficient the American
airline industry is I hope Southwest
does right by these passengers and gives
them more than a free upgrade for the
next flight they have to take care of
these people this is one of the things
that will leave you
you know scarred forever and the stock
price is taking a huge slide today
recovered a little bit but Southwest
it's ranked really high according to the
other airline's but at the same time
they've had a lot of PR disasters
they've had the computers crash they've
had these emotional support dogs bite
people they've had fights that had to
drag women out that were fighting and
kicking and screaming they serial over
booked flights they don't do that
anymore so hopefully Southwest can
recover from this and all these people I
hope are recovering - Greg one thing
that's really different now than even in
since 2009 this last time that there was
a fatality on a plane is that social
media now allows you to actually be
experienced and like to see it and to as
Julie was saying that's a quite
harrowing but we wouldn't have known any
of that before social media yeah we
probably wouldn't have led with it
because I don't think we should have led
with this story I mean no we have 40
million flights a year there wasn't a
single commercial jet fatality in 20 in
2017 but you can't lead a show with
flights that land safely because that's
boring but what to your point which is a
very good point because you have the
video and stuff that makes it more
interesting and sometimes that makes a
story bigger than it should be in many
different ways
it's amazing when you see the flight
trackers you ever see the video when
they show all the flights going over
every little inch of the country how
safe it actually is because yeah
ever happens yeah I mean thousands of
flights you know up in the air all at
once it's amazing how they're able to
make sure yeah I mean when you think
about the fact that six hundred and what
six hundred thousand people die every
year from heart disease and I guess you
know that's not as exciting a visual no
but there's something serious here which
is my old boss Ben Bradlee at the post
used to say we don't cover all the safe
landings at national that's my point and
that's your point and I understand it
but it's the same time to understand
what happened with someone in a window
seat who is being pulled out of the
window while the plane is in the air
Greg and other people are over there you
know and there according to the accounts
on board she was bleeding there's blood
all over I mean that's a pretty wild
experience what happens Kimberly from
the legal standpoint from the from the
Southwest lawyers in TSP lawyers etc and
also possibly for the passengers well
right obviously there's probably gonna
be a tremendous amount of like you know
civil lawsuits but it's gonna depend on
the results of the investigation what
they determined happened whether there
was human error whether but there was
any kind of conscious disregard for a
known risk you know acting in defiance
of that or just negligence or saying
okay you know what we'll let this plane
fly for however many more hours when
perhaps they should have backed we don't
know this yet but these are the types of
things that they will be looking for in
terms of the records now we are pretty
scrupulous in terms of how we keep our
records and all of the flight tracking
maintenance it's very important because
one time is one time too many if you let
a plane go up in there and you clear it
to fly and something is you know
terribly amiss so things can happen in
general so if there's any idea of
something that's malfunctioning or
engine lights going on or something like
that
very curious to see the flight history
for the past you know as a 5200 flights
that this particular airplane went on
generally speaking it's you know
phenomenal I'm Aeronautics for a 737 and
have been proved to be very reliable
have a tremendous safety record so now
we'll have to see what went wrong here
and how Southwest can improve upon it
they do it a lot of short flights quick
commuter flights that's up a thing with
their airplanes